but first kamala
can't and won't that's the focus of
tonight's angle
today vice president harris traveled to
texas to check the border box
and play a game of make-believe it is
important to be clear
is working to build a fair and a
functional
and a humane immigration system we feel
very strongly about that
and as you know we inherited a tough
situation and
in five months we've made progress but
there's still much more work to be done
but we've made progress
progress lies and more lies
number one she and biden were not handed
a tough situation on the border
they created a disaster on the border
they did
thanks to trump's remain in mexico
policy and of course aggressive interior
enforcement
illegal border crossings were driven way
down under trump
and number two by progress she means a
total abdication
because most americans define progress
at the border as a reduction in the
number of illegal crossers
but for biden and harris i guess it's
kind of right progress means an increase
in crossings
regardless of the harm and cost to the
american people
now this is i like to call this open
borders collusion
at the highest levels of our government
the biden administration is committing
an
ongoing crime against our basic
sovereignty
a conspiracy to undermine the rule of
law and their refusal to do what works
to stem the flow of humanity into
america
now this fiscal year alone border patrol
has intercepted
nearly a million migrant crossers at our
southern border
we don't even know how many of them have
been released either into the interior
part of the country
but you know that number has to be
staggering
if harris were a serious person who
actually put america's interests first
she would have traveled to where the
action is in the rio grande valley
but of course that would have been too
embarrassing and revealing
because there the border arrests stand
at a whopping
271 000 and counting this fiscal year
so of course kamala harris decided to
skip that region
and instead visit el paso which has two
and a half times
fewer border arrests and just for good
measure a democrat mayor
now everything i saw today was border
theater
from beginning to end there's nothing
serious about enforcement
and she was always in search of mythic
root causes
the work that we have to do is the work
of
addressing the cause the root causes
i'm very excited about the potential as
we have talked with these
congressional leaders and the secretary
the focus that we have
placed on the root causes you can't just
react to a problem without solving it
at its roots now everyone knows that
root causes it's just washington's way
of saying
we have no intention of solving the
problem
and despite the gravity of all of this
harris was only on site
for about six hours in texas and much of
that time was spent glad handing at the
illegal crossing hot spot known as
the el paso international airport
now of course the veep spun a totally
fictional version of events today
how did you decide that right now was
the right time to make your first trip
to the border
well it's not my first trip i've been to
the border many times i'm the person in
charge of the response
i said back in march i was going to come
to the border so this is not a new plan
if her dissembling weren't so
infuriating it would be
absolutely hilarious because with so
much time having passed the vice
president's border jaunt is kind of just
a sideshow at this point
it's a distraction from the real story
because while she embarrasses herself in
el paso the biden dhs is moving
full steam ahead on dismantling our
border protections and immigration
system
just days ago they notified congress
that they were going to release tens of
thousands of illegals into the
interior of the country who were
previously denied
entry under the remain in mexico
programs they're going to
pluck them out of mexico bring them back
and release them
isn't that nice that's not all just
today biden's team is furiously trying
to figure out
how to rescind the trump-era policy that
allows for the immediate rejection
of illegal border crossers due to covet
because they care so much about coven
this outrage aligns perfectly with
something harris said today about what
our obligations are as a country
that we have a responsibility and if we
ignore that responsibility it will visit
itself upon us in a very domestic way
she was talking there about the region
central america and mexico so apparently
our responsibility
is to other countries thus not only will
the middle class and all americans
frankly be hit with a higher cost of
living because of inflation now
but you can also expect wages to
stagnate as well
all because biden bowed to the business
lobby in the far left of course
and they are fine with having a glut of
workers because the glut of workers in
the united states
keeps wages flat certainly keeps them
from rising
so once again we see the ugly truth
about today's democrats
although kamala harris was put in charge
of the border issue
she not only can't do it because she's
in way overhead
she won't do it because shutting down
illegal border crossers
means putting america first and why
should they ever want to put a
systematically racist country first
that doesn't make any sense they don't
think it's their responsibility to try
to lift your standard of living
or ensure your schools are functional or
to make sure
your seat streets are safe because if
they did
they would do whatever it took to secure
that southern border
and instead their goal is to
fundamentally transform
our nation and its culture so those
borders
you bet keep them wide open they're only
going to care
about the border about enforcement when
they see that their actions or in this
case inaction
has really cost them votes and very soon
it will be time to make them pay and
that's the angle
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else